you mentioned t.y hilton earlier as a
possible
addition to the packers with cap room
they would get from restructuring aaron
rodgers contract
sammy watkins visiting the colts that's
the team that's employed ty hilton since
2012 sammy watkins visited
the ravens yesterday would you rather
have watkins or hilton at this point i
would rather have t
y hilton i would ty hilton has been you
know available
more uh i just i i wouldn't trust sammy
watkins
that's the biggest thing i mean we're
talking about a guy who's played a
handful of games over the last four
years
so that would scare me to death you know
ty hilton still got some tread on the
tires
yeah he might not be as explosive as he
once was but it's still damn good
like when i evaluated t.y hilton to
start a free agency i still went man guy
can still get open
guy can still run routes guys still has
enough speed to scare you deep
watkins you know it's hard to evaluate
watkins because you don't even know like
oh is he playing today in 80
is he actually healthy i don't know i
don't really feel like i saw him healthy
the majority of last year i mean i feel
like the super bowl was the last time we
saw him healthy i'd be scared to death
to pay sammy watkins i really would
uh i would certainly have t y hilton
back if i were the uh indianapolis colts
i agree with you as well and you know
look i i feel bad
saying that but it's it's the truth
yeah give me the all right um
total number of games averaged per year
that sammy watkins has played in
during his seven year career the over
under is ten and a half oh i i'm gonna
say it's under
i mean i gotta think it's like he's
probably at like eight games a year or
something like that right
womp womp he's at 12.2 games per year
wow that's what's a little surprising
there is this narrative that he's never
healthy
he played in 10 games last year 14 the
year before
10 15 8 13 and 16. he was had 16 starts
as a rookie but i know
it was wear and tear soft tissue
injuries foot
problems when you're a speedster those
are the things
we talked about with desean jackson yeah
recently those are the things
a little bit it doesn't take much to
keep you from having that top end speed
and that's been the issue with sammy
watkins yes mike and you know that
it's also like he played in 10 games
last year
whoopty do he wasn't even close to 100
in some of them so that's where that
number is a little skewed and you can't
buy into that to to
a degree it's always like well sammy
watkins hasn't practiced he played this
week
you know but you know what what kind of
money can you throw out to a guy
that's like that yeah the year before i
th you said 14 games but there was games
that year two i remember where it wasn't
a hundred percent
he's out on the field doing that but i
don't know how much change you can throw
his way
he had 37 receptions for 421 yards last
year
in the most high octane offense in
football
so you know that that in itself i think
says a lot and i just can't imagine
anybody signing him to big money
it it uh it's that lure of what he
can exactly when healthy
with the season on the line inspired by
devonta adams running by richard sherman
in the nfc championship
game running by and using the same
technique to run by sherman in the super
bowl making a key catch that contributed
to the super bowl win
that's what you're paying for the
possibility that it's all going to work
out that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports